you have a lot to do even those socks
are suspended at least trading from the
NYSC all right so it's important to
remember that this is the NYSC that's
suspending trading stocks listed on the
New York Stock Exchange still trade on
any number of other been correct they're
still trading on the nasdaq still
trading on all batches markets this is
just the NYC shutting down their systems
as they deal with an issue there have
been sort of a stream of these alerts
that come out explaining the issue
earlier they say they're probing
technical issues in some symbols and or
a while doing this let me just bring up
a truck taking a look at the volume of
trading at the new york stock exchange
so that you can actually put this into
some context because trading has been
moving away from the floor for many
years and what about eighty percent of
the of the trading is is outside the
United States I mean outside of the NYSC
that's right and you know when you talk
about the NYSC anymore you're not really
talking about the floor at all you're
talking about their electronic
marketplaces and the market MKT as they
call it that exchange that the all
electronic exchange for Malay
Archipelago that they bought several
years ago so basically you're looking at
one of the biggest stock exchange
operators in the world right now it's
shutting down trading the other
exchanges should be able to handle a lot
of the volume but this is sort of an
unprecedented issue we've had Nasdaq
shut down trading a few years ago when
one of its computers that processes
trades crash NYC hasn't really had to
shut down like this as far as I can
remember so this is it's it's a big
issue DD even during the the financial
crisis one of the points that Duncan
Niederauer then the chief executive of
the New York Stock Exchange said that
the exchange continued to function
normally and process all trains right
even during Hurricane sandy all the
major exchanges said we should be able
to trade through this it was just a
matter of getting people at brokerages
and traders getting to the office that
was what shut it down for sandy they
were prepared and could have potentially
just traded right through the aftermath
of Hurricane sandy but this sounds like
some sort of connection problem
connecting either the New York Stock
Exchange his own computers or its
computers outside to other traders so
still developing we don't know a lot
about exactly why they did it but it you
know
now the New York Stock Exchange is not
trading not trading and does this then
mean that there may be will be some
follow-on effect because if you can't
get a price discovery for a certain a
number of shares in other words if
you're trying to sell or buy large
blocks of stock would this have a
specific effect on that it in theory it
could it's hard to say how it will all
flush out I mean the other exchanges
should be able to absorb all the
training and the dark pools the
electronic exchanges there are so many
across the country dozens of them that
they should be able to absorb all this
volume but that said you know who knows
there's all sorts of questions that this
is going to raise and we'll hopefully
we'll know more so well you're taking a
look at a live shot of the floor of the
New York Stock Exchange and it looks
almost empty intermediate traders so go
ahead so sorry I just to jump back in
here you know I spent two years working
on the floor of the stock exchange I
know a lot of the guys down there the
reason the shot you're seeing right now
looks empty is because everybody has
moved over to one side of the floor and
they are all currently standing at the
operations ramp trying to get
information now what one of the problems
I've talked to a bunch of guys down the
floor just just now is that they've
broken all trades and sent them back to
the broker level so everybody outside of
that blue line that that surrounds all
of these trading posts are the brokers
standing out there they've got their
orders but they can't put them through
for technical reasons the New York Stock
Exchange when Duncan Niederauer left and
management shifted hands kind of fired a
lot of the operations guys that would
normally deal with the problem like this
for the floor traders right because
floor trading is obviously separate than
the computer trading now they don't have
that layer of management and they're not
able to get the information disseminated
to brokers like Felix so you see in the
background they're standing in his camel
jacket so right now nobody on the floor
really knows what the trading glitch is
and previously you may have had a better
chance of having the human traders
actually be able to work some of this
order flow through but you can't do it
right now because they can't deal with
the technical glitch right and even the
humans you see on the floor there are
actually trading over handheld devices
anymore they're not there's no moral
right there's no Alvin open outcry
madam what if you could just talk a
little bit about what the actual process
is right now for someone who would want
to trade stock I mean what would it be
ormally over you could get your order
down to a broker for example you could
get your order down to Jonathan cortina
or joe greco they sit outside of the
blue line there but they can't put the
counterfeit reorder rhythm because they
would normally want to go into one of
the traders he would put it through as
Michael mentioned his hand held and then
they would you see what price you could
make the market right but they can't do
that right now for some technical reason
that isn't being that isn't being
exposed isn't being disseminated to to
the people on the floor all right as you
speak I just want to bring up a chart of
the Dow intraday so that people can see
what was going on earlier today and then
you see this flat line that just occurs
just before noon to just as we come up
on trading today here at noon a little
bit more on the actual process of what
goes on now versus what used to happen
when you had the open outcry you don't
have any real market makers on the
flurry of no one committing their own
capital do you to the inventory of
stocks that are there you do they're
just all electronic now it's all shifted
obviously to you know high speed
electronic market makers so for your
average we don't have a commitment
really do they I mean do they have a
commitment to maintain liquidity in a
variety of stocks well that's that's
open to debate yes and no you know not
quite you know a lot of people to argue
not quite as firm as as the guys on the
fell even back in the day it was really
a commitment of honor wasn't it right if
you were truly freaked out you were
going to get out of that market as well
you weren't going to risk too much of
your own capital there but yeah ever
since reg nms put the genie back in the
bottle up to put let the genie out
bottle to say that that idea has been
gone which is made I guess putting
through trades cheaper but it's also
made the whole market a little bit
darker and Messier and more difficult to
understand just a report that our
producer been geldin is telling me that
there is a spokeswoman from the New York
Stock Exchange who says that this the
stock exchanges shut down for technical
reasons certainly an underwhelming
statement there but it's important point
out that this connection issue appear to
pop up before the market even open today
so it's not necessarily a result of
heavy trading we're seeing today you
know with
with the market down but certainly can't
be good if you combine this with what
has been going on in China and the ban
on stock sales in china by corporate
executives or large shareholders for six
months so you've got a combination of
effect not being able to get prices on a
variety of issues right and these these
issues do tend to scoop people a little
bit and definitely can undermine
confidence a little bit this can smooth
people a lot I mean I wouldn't want to
be an alarmist or a sensationalist but
look it's scary to see the headline New
York Stock Exchange suspends all trading
this should be the NYSC kind of the last
bastion when everything else fails these
guys on the floor are the people who
make it work and if you don't have
anyone on the floor there's no one to
there or fewer people to make it work
then you don't have any I just want to
show the stock trading so far today and
you can take a look at this the big move
down that started earlier in the day
then a bit of sell a bit of buying and
now as we see approaching noon we see a
considerable sell off the dow is down
more than one-point-two percent S&P 500
down more than one and a quarter a
percent we've lost them more than two
hundred and six seventeen points on the
Dow and moving lower as well on the on
the sp500 the Nasdaq has also declared
what they call self-help against the
NASDAQ and the amex we'll get more
details you see the Nasdaq also falling
nearly one-and-a-half percent my and
self-help is a process that they invoke
when it means they're having problems
communicating with the new york stock
exchange and so they're no longer going
to route orders to them you know
exchanges are sort of required to route
Wooders to wherever the best pricing
best execution right so now you know the
whole market is basically operating
around the NYS either their routing
orders to each other but avoiding the
NYC until they get this issue solved you
know again it's important remember if
you are trading on your etrade or your
schwab account at home or even if you're
a hedge fund any institutional trailer
right you can still trade these new york
stock exchange listed stocks they are
still trading just not on the NYC all
right and also word for the New York
Stock Exchange that all open orders as
you said earlier have been can't